[Music]
in a tax fraud news is that time of the
year you know yep true submitted by what
up JK what uh a man reported income of
eighteen thousand what the IRS sent him
a refund check for nine hundred and
eighty nine hundred eighty thousand like
a million dollars your any only made uh
and no one and no one checked what do
you do that makes mom can I check it out
like your net worth off when I worked at
this sneaky look when I worked at the
bank there was always checks and
balances right like every teller
whatever had their set limits like if
you get a transaction that requires X
amount of money your manager has to
check that you know if you're dealing
with the business clients or whatever
you hit an X amount of deposit or
whatever then it blocks you now a
manager has to come in or supervisor s
it clearly like no one here thought that
was that a misprint just played a couple
zeros off yeah so let me tell you the
whole situation might be really good I
plainly get this dude is them on of
Tampa and so he is of Tampa Tampa Tampa
I'm on crystal fair Blanchett Blanchett
of Tampa Florida Florida
you will need that is dice of America
he's never years old he must be really
good at math I haven't practice my
Spanish okay I could do this I get si si
si okay so back in February 2017 boom
again back in February 2017 he
electronically submitted a self prepared
income tax return listing his occupation
as freelancer he had w-2 forms from a
nursing home and its restaurants in Utah
so the nursing home was in Tampa the
restaurant in Utah 1w2 showed seventy
thousand ninety eight dollars in wages
and 1 million dollars of federal income
tax
holding but in reality he was just paid
two thousand ninety eight dollars with
no text withheld and then the other w-2
was accurate which was a $1,399 an
income with no withholding so he like
photoshopped the first of yes he faked
it and then you let me see if this [ __ ]
works in the check came through the
check came through because the US
Treasury issued him a nine hundred and
eighty thousand dollar check for a
refund yep and so he deposited the money
into two accounts but then anyway but
the funds were frozen for suspected
fraud has to be yes so that bank closed
the accounts and sent him a cashier's
check for that amount oh my god
Oh supid is that like we don't want to
deal with whatever you're up to that
what they did deal with it because they
cashed it today gave him cashier's check
is literally cash it's untraceable if
the bank was frozen aren't they supposed
to just wait I don't know but the policy
so as soon as that's fraud the account
gets frozen no money gets released so
someone there throw hard that's a good
thing for Friday what thank you sir
yeah do you entrust okay that means a
lot of folks happen a [ __ ] happen at
the IRS and a [ __ ] happen at the brain
multiple levels at the bank to because
nine million you're no longer it sits
like a regional thing I mean yeah nine
hundred thousand you have to get like a
pool from like a branch yeah a lot of
money mean cash like a ten thousand
dollar check
but now like a bunch of [ __ ] sttr
yeah well yeah I never try to cash
anything that large cuz I never got to
check that large make sense yeah dude so
then he used that money the cashiers
check money to open a money market
accounts with grow Financial Credit
Union and so he fossil falsely
represented that the funds were from the
estate of his deceased father this guy
is really good at fraud catch me if you
can brawl this is Jason Bateman from
plug the holes arts he's not good
because he should have just left the
[ __ ] country
yeah ventually because this article's
out he transferred various amounts of
money among various grow financial
accounts so then he ultimately withdrew
forty nine thousand one hundred and
seventeen dollars in on interest in the
form of a cashier's check they didn't
mention interest but then so he ended up
buying a 2016 silver Lexus rc350 I don't
know what kind of car that is but by
that time it's a coupe sixty grand with
RC yeah no our C's our C's yeah like the
little Cupra it is it's like a sports
car but it's slow there was a problem
and so usually they issued a warrant a
seizure warrant a federal seizure
warrant and so an IRS Special Agent cut
took the Lexus and the remaining nine
hundred and nineteen thousand two
hundred and fifty one dollar balance and
his accounts did they uh did he keep the
[ __ ] forty nine thousand then he got
[ __ ] probably off the interest so the
thing is the IRS is trying to get back
another eight hundred and nine dollars
at which is the amount that progressive
insurance refunded him after he
cancelled his policy because he no
longer had bad I mean the car looking
wild with money he's [ __ ] if you're so
smart to do and I guess desperation is
the answer that I'm gonna ask anyways
but uh if you're so smart to be able to
do all this fraud and do all these
things aren't you aren't you smart
enough or logical enough like I know the
answer to that I'm probably gonna get
caught well I mean I think it's
desperation I think you read my mind I
said it I know stupid smart that's a
pretty dumb yeah maybe he's like I can't
believe this shit's [ __ ] working yeah
cocky and he really was like oh I feel
like you think it all the way through
and then you're like I'm 80% you're
gonna get caught I shouldn't do this or
you're so [ __ ] smart you're [ __ ]
living in Paris with a new name and a
new idea in your fine
I know what happened was I'm gonna just
try it and then thinking that it's not
gonna work
and it actually does and he's like hole
[ __ ] what I do with the money now
alright I've been deposit I got Rosie
[ __ ] tax fraud on a wind and they give
it as they give a check right [ __ ] okay
and then he keeps doing [ __ ] and it
keeps working I don't know if 980 is
enough to leave and retire I think so
how okay you can in America how long can
you live off a million dollars in the
middle of Cambodia nan emergency go to
Tennessee anywhere I mean I thought the
point was to leave the country I know I
know but I'm just saying you're talking
about the budget deal like you could do
I'm saying you could do it here yeah
that's six figures for ten years that's
a lot of money for the middle of country
fast money means fast spending not true
so I'm wondering especially if it's on a
with my taxes yeah you did get a
whatever Lexus uh how's it go with the
big boy
how does it me go with the LS at least
if you're gonna Lexus where is he you
gotta go with the big bombers afraid
that other countries are gonna steal my
money that I stole you didn't steal any
money no no like if I stole money I got
to a different country I don't feel sick
I feel like dirt I'm like clinching my
bank account purse like the government's
gonna steal from me like I feel scared
you can't be a hypocrite you stole I
know but that's why I'm if you're gonna
steal it don't you want your money to be
yours and you distrust other people cuz
you know how [ __ ] up you are you can
still bake out a first world country so
you flee to Mexico but if you have like
Swiss bank
I hope there's a Chase Bank in Mexico oh
I don't know oh but they might freeze my
account yeah yeah I wouldn't bank it I
would catch something on you didn't you
alias cash nothing else go to Panama
don't they fun all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
through there you know what I do I think
I would go country shopping cuz that
would be my exit strategy you got a
country you literally not buy a country
but I would shop around to see which
country I want to run away
research yeah don't just say I'll go to
Mexico like I don't know anything I
don't know I'll study Spanish like I'll
make sure that no that's what I'm saying
before I even steal the million dollars
that's how smart I am with my getaway I
want to I want to get away in Compton
I'm not trying I'm not trying to get
away and be surprised like actually this
place has mosquitoes and I don't like it
this food sucks view yeah but you know
the are a bummer
waste of money yes true right buy a home
imagine you did this heist yeah and then
you're like [ __ ] doctor my you bread
they have nothing but pita bread your
absence in like criminal movies right
there's so set it like the hideout of
the mansion movie yeah like this
bathroom sucks i hate this tile
don't you hate this tile it really like
plant if you have problems here in the
states you're gonna have problems
anywhere you go right well that's what
people think I'm gonna scape I'm gonna
be in paradise well guess what you've
been living in an area that has four
seasons you don't even know what it's
like to be in a tropical zone [ __ ] when
you go to that tropical zone there's
only two [ __ ] seasons monsoon and hot
and when you're living that you're gonna
miss the snow whatever you're gonna miss
your family so this is what I will do Oh
visit different countries I would make
friends there and I would feel like a
second home and I'll be like you know
what I've already established a little
bit of a route here so wherever I go
whether it's Thailand Cambodia or
wherever I decide to run away - what
about when you're forty or sixty then
what what I mean you keep running yeah
you go based when you're on board but
what's your move what's your run away to
that country just stay there interesting
yeah yeah you you planned your
retirement out right so you go I'm gonna
do this big job one last job you get all
that money you go to that country your
you have your friends there you probably
feel like you could get married there or
whatever or you could bring your family
there and that's probably what people
use as America maybe think about that
Amy
America's the getaway country for people
yeah this is a hard get away country
though expensive one and they don't want
you in here yes Chinese people do that
here oh yeah that's true yeah well
they're not doing anything illegal what
they'll do is like don't make a lot of
[ __ ] money the politicians by
kickbacks and things that are kind of
like hush-hush bribe money and then they
get [ __ ] ton of money and then they
buy homes out here and then they send
their kids and then they send their
wives and they [ __ ] exit and then they
come here cuz it's legal everything
they're doing is legal I think once it's
illegal that's [ __ ] hard that's true
yes so the craziest thing here is that
this dude lazier has not been charged
with the federal living cut what cuz
they just worry about it got everything
back um it wasn't really stolen no use
it no if I try to kill you and they
revive you oh no harm no foul it doesn't
work no idea it doesn't but he's not
charged for anything so I'm just trying
to see what they can catch him maybe I
can catch one maybe he's not charged yet
or his country shopping maybe not yet
yeah but they're saying um so the IRS
won't comment on this or anything so we
cuz they're like what about the even
more crazy because in the year that he
got his 980 thousand dollar check the
average tax tax refund was about three
thousand dollars wrong oh come on this
fool might be so smart that he knew that
if the IRS made a mistake by sending how
to check that's Bear full and they can't
punish him by crime but they can't
because he forged I don't know
there maybe there's a bigger conspiracy
and they're still waiting to figure out
what happened like it was an inside job
cuz it because a for sure if you focus
it will [ __ ] with your tax stuff you're
going well guess not it all right try it
maybe let me know how it goes look at
this guy I know I want you to try for me
I don't want to [ __ ] with my taxes that
[ __ ] scary no I'm scared
there's IRS agents that's how they got
Al Capone
Oh al is scary
[Music]